our NFL player smart  what you mean you just gotta move one  gummy to make it one here two three four  to reverse what this order is  like going that way what's the order  one two three four  but now I want there to be one two three  four going that way  and you can only move one gummy  if I touch it I got a movie or like I  mean yeah I like killing it like  multiple trash  you could try  all right but the time is two three four  yeah the timer is going you want you  want one  two  three  I just want there to like I want the  this order to be reversed but you only  can take one gami out of its place to  make that work  you want me to tell you  right when it gets to like two seconds  I'm gonna tell you  did you get a pee no it's just someone  to tell you  give me a kiss it'll give you good  you got to spin come on  one two three  all right let me tell you  I can't tell if the timer stopped did it  look at you I knew I was dating a smart  man took you a bit yeah